[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
July 17th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
managers are making a push to get
Workers into the office on Mondays and
in some cases it's not going over very
well with workers wsj's Anne-Marie
chaker joins us so Anne-Marie many
companies are still on a hybrid schedule
what days do workers tend to come into
the office yeah the big days tend to be
in the middle of the week right so
Tuesdays Wednesdays and Thursdays those
are the days that companies ask workers
to come in they can set their own
schedule sometimes they see who else is
going to be there they can schedule a
desk
Fridays is tends to be the day when most
people work from home
and Mondays it's a little bit more hit
or miss all right so then why the focus
on Mondays from the companies so Mondays
has always been the let's get out of the
weekend and get back to work day and
companies are finding that workers tend
to blow off Mondays a little bit they
tend to make it the day when they come
back from their weekend so they'll be in
the car literally phoning it in or
answering emails and there's a movement
called bare minimum Mondays even where
workers Advocate like really taking it
easy on Monday so that they give
themselves a break and don't burn out
managers are fed up with this and they
are starting to say hey we want Monday
to be in person in the office get your
butt in your chair at 9 00 a.m and let's
treat Monday like any other day I mean
I've heard of a case of the Mondays but
it's got its own movements among
employees right yeah there's the whole
movement on Tick Tock and elsewhere
where employees post videos of
themselves lighting candles taking it
easy on themselves and telling
themselves not to go too crazy on a
Monday but before the pandemic Monday
was the day when a lot of departments
would get people together and map out
the plan for the week why do a lot of
workers feel differently now no it's
funny isn't it Monday was the day when
it wasn't all that strange or bizarre to
get in an office meeting and sort of
plan the week and managers are saying
what's the big deal that this is
something that is not unusual for us to
want to map out the week get our goals
and we've written a lot about burnout
and employees saying that we need to be
treated as adults and the work is going
to get done but it's going to get done
at the pace that we want it to get done
so it's this conflict now that we're
seeing in workplaces all over the
country now you've spoken to managers in
specific situations who've asked their
workers to come in on Mondays how'd that
go over not very well there was an
example in the story of of a company in
Philadelphia it was an economic
development company and the manager said
to his employees look we gotta show the
flag we got to show that like we're here
in the office and supporting businesses
around us and he chose Monday in
particular as the day when he wanted to
see everyone and meet and the younger
employees really resisted this idea and
finally they came to a truce where they
agreed to have their planning meeting
every other Monday but it's also where
people are in their walks of life right
some people who have like small children
or a lot of responsibilities at home may
feel more strongly about wanting to have
that flexibility others who are at a
phase of life where they want to be out
and about and more social might also
feel more strongly that the office is a
good place for them and managers might
want people in the office but at the end
of the day the work has to get done
regardless of where someone's desk is is
there room for compromise here Friday
has been the day that like everybody
kind of agrees on not to touch so we
might be seeing more if you don't agree
to this we're gonna we're gonna take
away Fridays and that could be something
that well everybody agrees on we all
want our Fridays so what could cause
some companies to become more strict
about workers coming in on Mondays yeah
so more Monday office mandates could be
ahead if the economy falters and workers
start worrying about job security so
employers might start to use that as an
opportunity to be more strict on the
number of days spent in the office so if
a company for instance goes from three
days a week to four days there's a good
chance that Mondays would be that
increased day all right that's Wall
Street Journal contributor Anne-Marie
Shaker and that's your money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]
foreign